let me guess
your dentist isn't your favorite person
that torture chair the sound of the
drill
all those metal instruments i get it but
i've come to a firm
in moscow which claims that all that
pain all that fear can become
just a distant nightmare with a little
help from 3d printers
i'm a bit skeptical about 3d printers i
don't really understand their purpose
so i want to test whether it's all hype
by getting fitted for my
own 3d printed invisible aligner
apparently it's goodbye to chunky metal
braces that make teenagers
all around the globe cringe and hello to
an invisible pain-free fix to uneven
teeth
so let's go
step one the scan
[Music]
step two design
so my scans have arrived right yes
so what exactly do you do here i'm
responsible for the initial evaluation
of scats
that's
[Music]
already existing construction
all the magic happens right here how
does the process actually work
that's right we take liquid resin and
pour it into the 3d printer
the liquid gets turned into a solid
model of the jaw for further work
and how long does it take one print
usually takes about one and a half hours
it's very similar to painting nails with
shellac when nails are put under
ultraviolet light to harden
the difference is that we use certified
medical products so that the models can
be worn
in the mouth so let's see how it's going
let's do that
[Music]
wow what beautiful teeth yes and all
yours
they're almost ready we have to finish a
few things and then pass them on let's
go
final step thermoforming so actually
making
the aligner
[Applause]
after thermoforming a group of
technicians put the finishing touches by
filing buffing and polishing the
products and this almost
microscopic attention to detail is what
this company
does best whether it's for an aligner
like mine
for custom implant components or for any
of the high quality equipment
it provides for dental labs
okay so moment of truth time to try on
my liner
you know what it's actually pretty
smooth and i don't feel that's changed
the way that i speak
looking back all of my teenage years
when i was going to the orthodontist
seems pretty old-fashioned it's a bit
tight but you know what it's not bad
and actually i have to admit the whole
process it was quick it was clean it was
comfortable
and it's amazing look look how taylor
made this is for me it's actually pretty
amazing that all this started
with just one scan a couple of hours ago
3d printers i do see now i was skeptical
i know
they're small things that can have a
really big impact and especially
for people who are terrified of the
dentist that is something
to smile about
you